In China, Dr. Li Wenliang,...
...a doctor who was reprimanded by authorities for sounding an early warning about the new coronavirus,...
...has died of the illness in a Wuhan hospital.
The global death toll from the disease reached 636.
In Japan, forty-one people...
...tested positive for the coronavirus aboard a cruise ship under quarantine in Yokohama harbor,...
...bringing the total cases aboard the ship to 61.
In Malawi, the group Human Rights Defenders Coalition threatened a mass demonstration...
...if the Electoral Commission chair, Jane Ansah, doesn't step down immediately,...
...following a court ruling ordering fresh elections.
In Russia, authorities repatriate 26 Russian children from al-Hawal refugee camp in Syria.
Russia prepares to accept 73 more children from the camp and continues to search for more.
Finally from Germany, preparations are underway for Storm Sabine that is expected to hit Sunday.
The storm poses a threat to life and infrastructure in Germany.